foreign  [Music]  ER let me tell you the story of the  space Viking Thor Odin he was no  ordinary man he was a God  after seeding planet Earth for the 500th  time Thor set off on a New Journey well  he got in shape  he went from dead body  and after all that he reclaimed his  title  as the one and only four  oh spoke to you soon Jane  [Music]  the old ex-girlfriend  what's up Emily three four years eight  years seven months and six days give or  take  for my uh sensing feelings  [Music]  all right  the only ones who Gods care about  is themselves  is My Vow  oh God she will die  I was gonna say that was very very  impressive what you did back there  it's just my first bad guy  [Music]  I never forget you first  [Music]  kill  have something worth fighting for  [Music]  let's see who you are and take off your  disguise  oh you flip too hard damn it  should we help them and eventually grape  [Music]